so i got a question for you i got to
quit last night i pulled up a bunch of
stats about guns
okay because i want to know stats about
guns what percentage of gun ownership in
the world
do you think is in the u.s all the guns
in the world what percentage you think
is u.s very high give me another you
want to give us a multiple choice or you
want us just a guess no i just want you
to guess so imagine out of all the gun
owners in the world
okay at least half there is 857 million
gun owners in the world
what percentage is u.s a quarter okay
you're saying quarter what do you think
it is
i'm curious louise out of all the
registered gun owners what percentage is
you us
let's say 15 i'm going to go lower 20 20
what are you going to say percent kai
i'm a quarter you said fifty
you said half stick two well okay sure
46
she wins okay 46 of gun owners
in the world are in the u.s think about
it okay
think about that that's a big number but
40 does that count multiple guns like we
know people that have 50 guns in there
no no no no this is just you're a gun
owner you're one
okay it doesn't matter how many you own
yeah you own at least one right
46 i'm sorry 46 of uh civilian guns
owned
okay you're right okay multiple guns
guns oh we have some people in the
middle
right that have now watch dozen guns in
there watch this who do you think is
number two country
who do you think is number two countries
australia you will never guess number
two country
and we know it's not venezuela okay
seven as well it's not australia who do
you think
number two if you're listening to this
who do you think is the number two
country that has the most guns
owned number two switzerland no india
india's number two sweden india how i
would have never guessed india of course
what do you mean there's a billion
people there and it's a democracy you
did the math is what you did but
71.1 bill 1 million guns are registered
on you know in india yeah
71.1 now watch what happens here okay
then i went in
and and i looked at different stats okay
uh on gun ownership statistic okay 42
of households uh own a gun in america 42
of households that's a big number by the
way 42
30 of individuals own a gun that means
three out of ten so in this room two
four
six out of six two of us own guns do you
own one do you own one
do you own one louise your whole family
has gone up but he doesn't though
he doesn't two of us do that makes about
sense i have enough for all of you
yeah there's plenty in that safe someone
comes in here to valuetainment
47 of male men own a gun
only 13 women 47 percent
to 13 one think about it who actually
needs it
who doesn't need it it's the other way
around of ownership my good buddy sean
lowry
shout out to him he says what's number
three what's number three i i i only
have top two right now i don't know okay
sean dude's a favorite gold and silver i
don't go bronze but he wants to go
around sean lowry find that outfit
sweden i think it's probably sweden so
why sweden so watch this i think
either sweden or switzerland that makes
you do like be in the military
are guns like a thing in norway is that
allowed is it a
guys these stats are about to get more
interesting this is i'm getting to a
question here okay
watch these stats check this out let's
go down to these
so we have male 47 female 13
white 33 non-white me
18 okay you're considered white just so
you know that
me not me come on man republicans
surprisingly
41 yeah democrats 23 percent
if there was a fight between if a civil
war broke let's not even go
there let's not even go there let's
olive branch independent yeah
27 good by the way uh actually
republicans have nearly twice as much
yeah guns they own as democrats shout
out to my republican friends out there
buddy i'm on your side when we're going
down to a war now come on now okay
so now here's here's some other stats
civilians defend themselves with a gun
an
estimated 990 000 times a year
civilians defend themselves with a gun
an estimated 990 thousand times it's a
lot of times probably a million times a
year yes
exactly americans use guns to frighten
away intruders 498
000 times you come into my house cha-cha
okay oh [ __ ]
something's going to go down if i want
to cheer up exactly and that crazy bag
handle okay
40 of felons decided not to commit crime
because they knew or believed the victim
was carrying a gun that's a very
going back to what she was talking about
40 but we're about to get to a question
here that kind of threw me off a little
bit i got two stats i'm going to bring
up i want to ask your thoughts on this
and obviously our expert gunman here uh
adam
27 years you know he's been watching
people with guns but never owned it
but educational level of gun owners you
ready education
gun education level of gun owners this
is a very weird stat kai
and i'm curiou i have my own uh uh
assumptions why this is but i want to
hear your thoughts
college post-graduates is the lowest
percentage of gun owners
30 so if you got an mba it's the lowest
percentage of gun owners yeah
then it's college graduates 37
some college 41 high school grad or less
42 so the more the education the less
gun ownership is the less that they're
saying
exactly let's have that i want to have
because i knew you were gonna love this
with your peers on your community
so educated people so if you have an nba
on the wall
there's a chance there's a lower chance
of you having a gun than a person
that barely has a high school diploma
why is that
go for i think that's just part of
culture right united states the more the
more
the more that you're in college yeah you
know you're working in a
high level career you're a lawyer you're
a doctor you're working as a
white-collar
business you're probably the less likely
you're going to be using a gun i don't
know
jared i think that it's because you feel
safer where you are
there we go because you're you're
educated you're probably typically
making more money you probably feel like
you live in a
safe place okay absolutely i agree the
fact that
the more income you make the more money
you make you're gonna live in a better
community so
obviously you're not gonna have a need
for guns okay that totally makes sense
to me but what also makes sense to me is
how long does it take does it take to
get an mba what's the timeline of
getting an nba kai
give me a timeline six to eight years is
that about a good timeline
you mean when you start college from the
day you're 18 years old you go to
college to get in your mba how long is
it yeah six to eight years
i mean okay yeah is it fair to say that
the people who are instructors in school
that we call them professors
that they probably don't like guns yes
one out of ten professors in school are
conservative nine out of ten are liberal
this is a statistic you can see from
washington post
this isn't something new so i don't know
how many times a professor is gonna say
i drove to school today and i had a gun
on me and i left it in the car or it's
just not gonna happen so the people that
are also
most people the people they're spending
most time with they're not
you know pro second amen they're not
saying hey let me go by you should
buy a gun to protect yourself so i think
it's also having to do with
who you're around a lot to have a lot of
influence on you not owning a gun i
think there's a part of it that's also
being influenced by the system that they
have because for it to be
41 42 to 31
high school degree you're barely
graduating high school 41
42 own a gun mba it's 30 31
there is influence going on is there a
correlation between um
education and guns just from a brain
capacity that's the other side
because also brain capacity i'll give
you the other side as well the other
side as well is
atheist atheist okay or agnostics or
those that don't believe in god
the more degrees they get many of them
that end up saying i just don't believe
in a god
right they typically are the ones that
are more you know they've had more
degrees so
what is that is it because they've been
able to figure it out for themselves and
they're a little less naive
is it because their surroundings is it
because the universities and colleges
don't pray anymore what is it so there's
a there's a
two ways you can look at this with
influence
you